British opinion has hardened hugely
against Harry and Megan and in favor of
the monarchy Harry has had a religion a
religious conversion he's been converted
to this the world
[Music]
but she believes in this yes what does
he do he found was the Invictus game yes
yes or badly injured soldiers do you
know what Invictus means
not victim
what means isn't it interesting isn't it
interesting it means not victim it means
unconquered it's it's from the Latin to
conquer he really doesn't see that he
doesn't see it but I'm I'm sure he I'm
sure he managed to go through six years
at Eden and not learn a single word I
mean I think that they're doing profound
damage to themselves he's an exile
um he's become to use uh I think an
appropriate word because he's been
treacherous he has become a traitor
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our fantastic
and returning yesterday's one of this
country's most prominent historians Dr
David Starkey welcome back to
trigonometry thank you it's so good to
have you on the show we've got lots to
talk about particularly the Royals we
want to get your take on that and I'm
sure it's going to be very interesting
that we'll have to stretch it out then
David but before we do one of the things
I'm pleased to see is that you've
recovered so if there was any recovery
to needed from the attempted
cancellation you're back you're speaking
of Oxford Union shortly you've been
welcomed back into the fold of society
is that is that broadly speaking right
I'm not sure that I was ever driven out
of the fold of society there's this
strange little world this tiny world of
smug self-satisfied people centering on
places like the guardian the BBC some
University common rooms certain
Charities the Civil Service that think
they are the world they are of course
not they're a little group of
self-satisfied people now those
self-satisfied people can do terrible
terrible things because they control
employment in many ways they control
they used to control BBC have virtually
Monopoly on the dissemination of
information the one thing they didn't
control is real Society saving so far as
people are frightened and yes there was
fear there was fearing not me I've never
been threatened
um
I lost only one semi-friend
one and he was the kind of person who
buys friends to give you an idea of the
quality of the man I once visited his
garden I complimented him on the White
Fox gloves he said yes yesterday I had
ten thousand planted that tells you all
you need to know somebody who buys Fox
gloves and friends real friends were
absolutely stalwart what they were
hesitant about doing
a lot of them was putting head above
parapet there was much support behind
this oh yes absolutely disgrace it was
shocking
um
not actually
much muscle
but then I decided that no one has ever
shot me up before many have tried
beginning with my mother
that explains
my mother as always mothers get you half
right she said your tongue will be the
ruin of you well it very nearly was
um it was it's also been the making of
me and it's this again we've seen the
same thing with Clarkson
um you know those of us who walk
tightropes can fall those of us who
parade on knife ages can get cut
um but above all you need a degree of
Courage you need a degree of
honest self-judgment admitting you were
fool yourself
um is a start but equally once in my
sense in my case one of outraged
Injustice
that an outraged sense of justice that
that the sheer disproportion and of
course above all the fact I wasn't
employed
yeah
if I depended on the University salary
I would have been lost is it why JK
Rowling can get away with it she's too
rich to cancel
um the retired have you noticed the most
outspoken academics are the retired
academics you look now at for example
history reclaimed David abulafia Robert
Frost
retirement it's not going to give them a
new lease of life it's given them a new
lease of freedom you can't be canceled
you can't for rather the whole as it
were enforcement machinery
dismissal professional
[Music]
restriction and whatever it doesn't
apply it's those who are in employment
it's those those are the ones who are so
vulnerable and then again as we would as
we've been talking about
um so that's that's the that's the fact
that the constructions apply in a very
very uneven way I mean I think I think
again you look at so many of those who
are making uh uh making the running uh
in the in the Revival because there's
undoubtedly it's very serious Revival of
free speech many many of them are the
elderly they're those out somewhat
outside those standing away from talking
about us
nobody so you're you're of a different
kind you are the world of the New Media
but then equally the the New Media were
precisely one of the means by which the
worst aspects you know through Twitter
and whatever of of cancellation was
enforced
um the the
in other words when when a world of
margins aren't we uh in which
Mass Society
enforces rules but equally there are so
many bits and you fall off the edge in
most interesting ways I mean I've always
argued that the uh if you wanted to do
really big pseudo-history stuff on
freedom in the west you'd said that
freedom is a little bit like the mammals
in the age of the dinosaurs these tiny
little creatures scurrying around
between these things and in the west
above all I think it's the fact that you
have the war between church and state
between papacy and Empire and there's
this little bit of space and the world
that we're in now with these gigantic
forces oddly enough it leave little bits
of space and people like us the the
smart clever little mammals can run
around these gigantic snorting posturing
dinosaurs and laugh at them and all
occasionally sort of unit you're
underneath so you can do horrible things
but David we need
descent is essential all progress I mean
all new ideas depend on heresy that the
heretic is the key figure the the person
who says to pick a crass and fruit
example no no the the the the the the
sun does not revolve around the earth
you somebody has got to break the
obvious somebody has got to say what
everybody thinks is untrue and again my
dear mother came in very useful I come
from a background of my narrative
religion quakerism and my mother was in
many ways profoundly conventional woman
in one sense over things like morality
and whatever but equally she had
a remarkably powerful sense that public
opinion is often wrong just because
everybody says something she would say
is not necessarily right I was also
brought up
um she was fiercely opposed to corporal
punishment so she made and hear me talk
about making a rod for her own back she
thought the right way to deal with the
child was to reason with them can you
imagine trying to reason with me
she nearly broke herself yeah but it it
gave me that sense that finally the
truth is there that it can be argued for
it can be defended again I was immensely
bearing in my my age I am born in 45 I
was immensely fortunate both in my
primary school and more more
particularly in my little grammar school
were 300 a boy's grammar um which had
been taken over by an astonishing
reforming Headmaster I think he was one
of the youngest in the countries I mean
his early 30s a man called James boy
eyes and he'd essentially abolished
corporal punishment I was going to say
capital punishment that had been the
previous decade but he'd essentially
abolished corporal punishment and the
school operated as far as it could on a
principle of argument and reason now
that's
um
of course you always find yourself
coming up against the fact that people
may say that they believe in reason but
when it touches things really tightly my
mother again
um her favorite word she was such a
bundle of contradiction was right oh
it's a matter of principle and this
little boy learned very quickly that the
principle is something that people
believe in so strongly that they won't
listen to reason on them
again at Cambridge with my um with with
my great teacher with Jeffrey Elton
always you know
um I've got the view where you know you
should be contemptuous of your elders
harsh to your equals and generous to
those below you apply that to me which I
did and at which point
surprisingly you know suddenly you know
you've rebelled against your
intellectual father but I've uh I've
tried I've tried not to fall into that
trap I'm sure I sometimes have David and
speaking of dissent uh I mean one of the
things that uh I found and I I don't use
this word lightly but genuinely shocking
was
to do with the royal family which is one
of the reasons we wanted to have you
back but at the tail end of last year
where you had this incident with ngozi
Fulani yeah and I just I it just seemed
to me that we've we've become deranged
in the way that we talk about these
things I mean that the way that story
was covered showed me that that bubble
that you talked about earlier I mean
their view of reality is so distorted
now that they are so brought into the
idea that the royal family is just one
racist Enterprise
etc etc what did you make of all that
I
I was I was profoundly shocked by the
way in which the entire case was
reported I mean I was listening that
evening uh when when when Fulani went
public uh she was interviewed on
virtually every channel I was in I was
in a car when my friend Ian Dale
interviewed her I have never heard a
more shameful and I say this and I'm
deeply fond of it I've never heard a
more shameful and sycophantic piece of
broadcasting in my life that there was
simply this prostration before this
woman who clearly had to be the voice of
absolute truth because of who she was
what she was what color she was and I
thought that was shameful uh it was
clear that it wasn't the story was a
complex one
um I was again profoundly shocked at the
response of the household of the Prince
of Wales immediately implicitly accusing
his godmother Lady Susan Hussey of
racism that I thought was shocking too
um the the dialogue was a very strange
one but then so when you actually looked
at negoti Fulani was she
um here was a woman with an
extraordinary conflation of names hussy
new Africa hasi was a gather as a member
of the church with large numbers of of
of African members of the congregation
she was clearly profoundly puzzled by
the the the union of two wildly
different tribal names uh here was a
woman who was wearing uh well come on
say it was almost a carnival version
of African dress it really was I mean it
was a sort of it was a sort of outfit
that what we were in the old days a
Victorian traveling circus would have
used to exhibit an African queen she was
wearing as much leopard skin print as
you normally only find on a bar stool in
Las Vegas and is it is it is it any
wonder that a woman who traveled with
the queen to Africa had seen the real
thing was completely puzzled okay the
interrogation probably went too far but
but here again
if I I you know what I could hear myself
as Susan Hussey I really could you have
the sense of
I'm puzzled by you yes I don't
understand you I don't understand what
you're claiming to be uh and of course
you know the whole game was played to um
as it were get maximum Maximum Traction
for again this this this view that
British Society particularly upper class
produced Society is fundamentally racist
that that she was challenging This
Woman's right to be British etc etc etc
but isn't it striking
yeah
Fulani goes out of her way to emphasize
not her British identity but her
pan-african identity which again very
many black commentators were saying is
something they find profoundly
problematic because of course it places
skin color above culture
which you know again gets us into uh to
to to to associate identity with skin
color surely it's racist so we are in
the cul-de-sac of absurdities and
paradoxes David the thing that really
struck me and you use your own example
and I think about this in that context
as well is that the amount of bad faith
that was so obvious in that engagement
that was not critically analyzed by the
media at all I mean if you and I were to
have a conversation as we might have
done when we first met and you said to
me all your foreign where are you from
or and I gave you some
obfuscatory answer and you want to know
but were you really from I'd be like I
know what David's asking he's asking
where I was born why don't I just tell
him and then we can have a conversation
about that and that's how human beings
connect
he was very clear from this engagement
that this woman was deliberately making
this into a big deal and nobody had the
balls to stand up and say it that's
right
um it again I mean I had a remarkable
conversation and I wish I could remember
his name it wasn't a history reclaimed
party and he was from
I think I think in the Balkans
um he
to a level that I would say for the fact
that he used he used ritual version of
his surname I would have had no
awareness whatever and what we we were
then talking about what was I supposed
to call him
um and I wanted to call him English
because he seemed to me to have
everything that I regard as English in
the sense of the use of language the
sensibility the culture and he was
saying no I can't be I have to be
British and I found myself it was really
odd I found myself arguing that finally
englishness has become a matter of
culture it is it is in the same way that
you despite
spelling constant time with the K
and
whatever in so many ways are almost as
English as you and I think we're good
we're going to I think see I think this
is the way forward
um I I have got this this this sense
again England increasingly is becoming a
place of the Mind in exactly the same
way that Rome was and for all the same
sorts of reasons a dominant culture
which was the center of a vast Empire
which itself is being transformed
ethnically precisely because of the
Empire coming back home and so on but
but the idea of roomness
[Music]
survived as as as an as a as a as a
mental and cultural identity uh and one
of course that was capable of being
revived hundreds of thousand years after
Rome had fallen I wonder if
we might be going that way this I'm
wondering but it seems to me that that
rather than just
sticking to the brief it's worth
exploring that thought but to return
because you want to talk about you want
to talk well we were wanting to talk
about the royalty of the royal family
and I think my question and the question
that I really want to ask you before we
get into anything to do with Harry Etc
is why does a royal family matter why is
it so important to this country David
it is the one continuous thread in our
history
um what I try to explain to people why
there are several ways in which you can
understand it but essentially and it's
the it is this utter Paradox of in its
English History it's it's not British
history it's English History it's this
utter Paradox of English History that
all the things that we think of as our
freedoms the security of property the uh
forms of representative government the
rigorous enforcement of law all happen
under monarchy are finally a creation of
it and it is their guarantor in other
words we are that most paradoxical of
things we are a royal Republic as in
fact
um Prince King Charles very clearly
understood uh in what I thought was a
remarkably good speech which he gave the
sort of invented like so much of the
exception the in invented speech when he
met both houses of Parliament in
Westminster Hall and emphasized the fact
we are a parliamentary monarchy now many
people think that that's a sort of
creation of democracy in the 20th
century it's not it goes back to the
very latest the beginning of the 14th
century in 1308 in a ritual that will
shortly be reenacted that's the
coronation and The Taking of the
coronation oath in 1308 Edward II was
forced to swear an oath that he would
obey and then Force the laws that shall
be chosen by my people shall be chosen
that's
it is unique in the history of the
English Monarchy in other words what I
want what I think is important about the
monarchy is that it shows that freedom
can be historically rooted but it's part
of a tradition that it is not a product
of the 19th century that it is not a
product of democracy that it is not a
product of Revolution that it's not a
product of a Bill of Rights although all
of those things at certain points enter
into the story the thing that finally
guarantees freedom in Britain
extraordinarily isn't the revolution of
the 17th century it is the restoration
of a monarchy this is the wonderful
Paradox of English History
do you think that in other words I'm
saying our history is monarchy it's why
I wrote a book called crown and Country
which is a history of England through
the monarchy it is the institution which
reflects us to ourselves now what the
relationship of that is to Charles and
Harry and the soap opera of all of that
is anybody's guess but I'm giving you
the high intellectual viewers yes and I
think it's one that is and I'm being
desperately serious about it because
remember every particularly this whole
new labor-ish new leftish University
College Constitution unit view of
political freedom and whatever that it's
all to do with the enlightenment that
it's all to do with written
constitutions that it's all to do with
Bills of Right and sort of doing what
more or less a newly enfranchised
Eastern European country would set up as
its structure of government
I've always gently tried to remind
people that the average age of a written
Constitution is about 10 years
that's they last no longer that that the
the you know the fact that for example
America was able to create a
Constitution which has endured is
absolutely unique there is no other
example
um that that compares with that and of
course it has an enormous downside as we
can actually see at the moment
um you you cement a rigidity you you get
to an area over the right to bear arms
and whatever you get you get you're an
absurd doctrinal rigidity whereas a
living and constantly re-vivifying
tradition such as we have or had and
should have I think is
the right way to handle human relations
David you talked about England being
this idea do you think we can have
England without the monarchy do you
think it could exist as a republic or is
it going or are those two things
incompatible
it it was tried wasn't it it was tried
in the 17th century that's exactly what
happened we did abolish the monarchy and
we lasted for 21 years and clamored to
have it back I mean repeatedly and the
obvious thing was for Cromwell to have
actually it was a clamor to make
Cromwell king
um the the
sense was that that the norm couldn't
work without the monarchy now I suspect
that's probably no longer true I think
that the the monarchy has become
so much of a formality that you could
I'm afraid
very easily see it vanish I think it
would be a profound error I think if we
did do what we did again in the 17th
century we would discover our absolute
vulnerability we have a
all the things you and I uh uh uh uh
talk about the the world of woke the the
the awful cesspit of race relations or
whatever these are forces which press
very very heavily on the whole of the
western polity it seems to me your only
resource against these things is finally
tradition
um and I now arguing against my younger
self
um it may be just that I'm getting old
it may just be that my mind is no longer
as sharp as it used to be but I don't
think reason is any defense against
these Horrors
I really don't I mean the in fact the
the horrors in my view
demonstrably arise from the reason gone
wrong the the uh the very fact that that
is so much of it's called critical
theory it's it's a kind of Reason become
cancerous it's it's a whole series of
intellectual movements that that as it
were have turned against the metabolism
of of the mind and and of society and
finally the anchor against them it is
our traditions of decency of good sense
of the way in which we do things and
this is what is so shocking for example
places like Oxbridge and particularly my
own University of Cambridge Once Upon a
Time the sheer notion of collegiality
the sheer notion of the relationship
between teacher and taught would of the
sheer reverence for learning itself
would have acted as a as a barrier and a
bulwark but the deliberate attack on
these Traditions the destruction within
my own lifetime of a sense of
collegiality the absence any longer of
common dining of of Dons who live in of
unmarried Dawns who give their whole
lives to their institution it means that
the barriers of tradition have largely
vanished there is nothing but reason
self-advancement or whatever and we can
see how totally inadequate they are you
know you go back to my own case and a
college for a mere moment of thinking oh
this is a bit of a problem through
somebody who has been involved in it at
a very high level and doing a great deal
of good for it for 50 odd years simply
aside like a soil Pursuit now that
represents in my view moral corruption
that represents the abandonment of
decency the things on which we really
depend reason reason I'm sorry isn't
much of protection look at the French
Revolution itself and the theory the the
the the absurdity of the goddess of
reasons is some half-naked actress um
from the comedy file says performing on
the altar of Notre Dame
um uh is is why book
pushes reason to one side reason can
very easily go mad it's
a rootedness of behavior and rootedness
of political institutions and one of the
things that most worries me about what's
happening in Britain is the increasing
contempt between our political process
which in many ways I share the the
parliament which used to be the a thing
of genuine okay everybody laughs at
Parliament and individual
parliamentarians but broadly that sense
of of pride in the thing seems to me to
have warm dangerously dangerously thin
um
and that worries me because
you know does that are you familiar with
that extraordinary story of Churchill at
the beginning of the first World War
he takes a young man late at night
they're wandering around the Palace of
Westminster because indeed I was last
week the small hours and they wander
into the Chamber of the House of Commons
dark who lights flickering vaspers maybe
electricity maybe gas at that point and
Churchill
invites this young man the Lord he says
pointing to the empty House of Commons
this is why we're going to win
now would anybody be confident
about doing that now that confidence in
the tradition of we were talking about
the Oxford Union that which of course
models its debating like the Cambridge
Union on Parliament does anybody any
longer have confidence that what goes on
in Parliament represents a genuine
discussion by debate and I think this is
an utter utter tragedy
um and it leaves us profoundly
vulnerable that that without that
security of tradition you have very
little
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russia men who clean up executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin side technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by man's escaped this stuff is
legit and will have you smelling like
royalty the good kind not prince Andrew
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code trigger 20. at manscape.com that's
20 up and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
we talk about tradition and we talk
about being profoundly vulnerable to me
the royal family are profoundly
vulnerable without Queen Elizabeth
because even people who identify as
Republicans who would openly question or
even mock them on okay practically
everyone I speak to in this country had
the utmost respect for our Queen
but the moment that she passed away
it seems that
They're Up For Debate and it seems that
they can be challenged and they can be I
mean I you know what I think you reflect
um that the very last phase of the
Queen's Reign okay
um that this you know this unchallenged
respect uh was very much a product of I
think really
only posts well for the last 10 years or
so I mean if you actually think at the
deeply challenged unrespect that was
directed to the queen that Diana's death
when when you you actually had Blair
seeing himself as having to protect the
monarchy against itself she was accused
of being cruel and feeling you know not
sharing the The Marvelous openness of
Princess Diana I mean the
um no I I think that that
I what I was surprised by was the
remarkable
warmth of the reception given to King
Charles I was actually very impressed by
the confidence with each which he acted
at the beginning of the Reign
um
I've been less impressed
by of course the current who are
um but then equally if you look at
opinion polls British opinion has
hardened hugely against Harry and Megan
and in favor of the monarchy and the the
and what again of course is striking is
what it's not even striking um the the
the the the patterns of support if you
want to call them sides they correspond
to that other great Great Divide in
British life uh in general you will find
Harry and Megan's supporters were
invariably remain voters and and you
know monarchists are invest Die Hard
monarchists are invariably lead voters I
mean there's there's a it's a very very
it's a very now the the overlap between
the groups two groups in other words not
not every not every remainder is a
supporter of Harry and Megan but all
supporters of Harry and Megan are are
are are on the remain side and so on but
what what is striking about those people
is of course the Die Hard supporters of
Harry and Megan by definition of
fundamentally anti-monarchist
um and uh the kind of source the kind of
groups that they're appealing to
particularly the extinct that
extraordinary Trio of people who
appeared in in the Netflix series when
when we were talking about
um the uh the uh Susan Hussey uh and the
uh and and the the negoti Fulani
business the the business when the the
the the the the race in the central
alleged essential racism of the monarchy
was being being discussed look at who
they were David olusoga um uh kahindri
Andrews and afwa Hirsch every one of
them a profound anti-monarchist
[Music]
um
so so you so you think it's it's an anti
it's an anti-monarchy thing but the
damage they're doing to the royal family
sure I'm not I really don't think so I
mean I think that they're doing profound
damage to themselves and the uh I mean
what's I mean the Harry is an exile
he's an exile
um he's become to use uh I think an
appropriate word because he's been
treacherous he has become a traitor
um and what I've said
earlier on it seems to me Harry has
undergone uh we we talk don't we
increasingly about
um uh uh woke about critical race Theory
as either religions or heresies Harry
has had a religion a religious
conversion he's been converted to this
the woman
[Music]
yes I said a beautiful woman will do
that too well exactly
the religions
but she believes in this yes yeah and so
what so what you have with Harry and
it's only with poor Harry because he's
not terribly bright and he doesn't
really understand all of this it's a
very partial conversion but you see this
poor man straddling
between two World Views the World Views
were not terribly bright who Ray Henry
went in the Army which traditionally
wrecked in a traditionally rescues them
gives them a purpose gives them a sense
of direction and he behaved admirably
and he also did things that were really
very striking and again one wonders
now quite how much he was responsible I
mean what does he do he found what I
thought was something astonishing which
was the Invictus game yes yes for badly
injured soldiers do you know what
Invictus means no
not victim
what means isn't it interesting isn't it
interesting it means not victim it means
unconquered it's it's from the Latin to
conquer he really doesn't see that he
doesn't see it but I'm sure he I'm sure
he managed to go through six years at
Eaton and not learn a single word
I'm afraid that really that really that
really is the level of density
you see you got the point instantly
right what he has done he created a set
of games which design percent of these
these men who've been I mean
I was born with club feet I find I've
got a very awkward relationship with
disability I can't look at those men
without wanting to cry and you look at
their courage their refusal to be
victims
um okay they're the kind of men who
Express themselves normally simply
physically but here they are saying
right I may be shot up but I can still
do I can still pull away I can still I
can still row I can still do whatever
refusing to be victims and here is this
man who creates a non-victim's games
playing the Perpetual role of victim but
about things and so petty it's so
trivial so absurd and I mean it is you
know it's always been the problem with
monarchy but on the one hand you've got
an institution which you know it is it
is freighted with 1200 years
I'm I'm not sure what it must feel like
I love I've got a sort of inkling what
it must be like to sit in that chair
that chair made Fred with the First with
the conquest of Scotland in the form of
the stone beneath it
um to sit in that chair in that building
that is built a century earlier for the
specific purpose of a coronation with a
text which hasn't changed very much
since the coronation of Edgar in the 9th
century that that extraordinary in in
front of all the great medieval kings
arrayed behind you in that great Arc a
kind of audience of your ancestors as
well as an audience of your subjects
and that that institution finished up in
producing Harry you know the the sense
of the
weight on the one hand and the feather
froth on the other but
David that's the nature of humanity well
this is what I was going to say give us
a historical perspective because I
thought I've been doing that all the
time and very well of course as always
but but on this particular issue I mean
primogeniture the idea that the Elder
son inherits titles and lands and so on
and the rest get nothing
is quite a long-running thing in human
history not yeah of course
isn't that born in the council house
grinding Poverty of Nottingham Cottage
you know um its rateable value would
have paid I would have thought for my
entire education a very successful
Counter Strike there David I'm wounded
deeply uh by by the appropriateness of
your of your response but you know what
I mean I do throughout history you have
had these spares as he's called himself
right and that is what that is the way
that it's been but is it how common is
what's happening now where the spare so
to speak seizes the microphone uh
whether we like it or not he's got a
huge book deal that millions and
millions and people if not a billion
people around the world are going to
read at least bits of it and this is a
guy who is you know getting his story
out quote unquote and maybe not
destroying the royal family as you say I
think you're right the Injustice of the
way that he's behaving is actually
galvanizing a lot of support for for the
monarchy
but he is tarnishing them the key is
slinging mud at least no you're
certainly trying to she's trying to how
is this common has this happened before
have we seen this in fact the problem of
spare Brothers is so acute that the uh
the uh the Ottomans the the the
Ottoman Empire the sublime Port that say
the rulers of turkey had a very simple
way of dealing with Brothers
you succeed as Sultan you invite your
brothers to a wonderful Feast the
following morning they are strangled
with the silken cord that's what the
Ottoman Empire did
I mean that would solve the hiring
problems
[Laughter]
so they might still be released a
posthumous publication you think there's
a clause
when I'm strangled with a silken cord
and again you you look repeatedly in
English History when you were fighting
about real things not about you know my
bedroom was smaller and you look for
example or indeed being pushed into a
dog bowl uh well the younger brother of
uh of Edward IV the Duke of Clarence was
pushed into a butt of Mumsy wine and
drowned I mean and it was the the
relationship between the three brothers
of the House of York uh between Edward
between George and between Richard is a
kind of s unit on steroids version of
what seems to be the case with with
Harry it's frustrated ambition it's
anger at being overlooked it's there's
even a struggle about wives of course
there is
um
and you would expect that to be the case
and the one one of the one of the great
successes of the English Monarchy for
much of its history was it didn't have
too many spare children one of the great
problems actually was was King Edward
III King Edward III I forget how many
sounds it's something like eight
um and he actually boasts in Parliament
about you know my marvelous activity
um at generating Sons but of course that
leads pretty well directly to the wars
of the Roses that you've got too many
rival Royal branches and what happens
when one of them fails or you you get a
an a a an absence of the usual kingly
qualities you've got all too many other
branches ready when they're ready to
step up and and to claim the throne
again one of the reasons that the the
monarchist survives or the torments of
the 17th century is that until the very
end until 1688 the Royal house doesn't
split
um that that younger Sons do not
as it were take up the line of
opposition normally that's what happens
again in 1618 in 1689 the solution to
the great crisis
um of the um of the Stuart monarchy was
that you had daughters who were prepared
to rebel against their father
David what I'm getting other this is I
mean it's fascinating what you're saying
but what I'm getting at is it seems to
me and again give us a historical
perspective because you're much more
knowledgeable of course in this era is
is it not unprecedented for the spare to
have this level of I mean you want to
call a power or influence on this one no
no it's not again Harry Harry has
carried out the equivalent of a modern
Rebellion I mean what what to do could
what what the man I was talking about
the one who finishes up in the butt of
moms in wine what he does he twice
Rebels against his brother and in an
unlike unlike Harry
um who is you know merely slinging mud
um at Williams
well more than that he actually once he
drives his elder brother from the throne
twice
right
um and it finally bumped off when it's
perfectly clear that he's dabbling with
another coup and then what happens with
the yet the younger brother still
Richard
um he murders his famously murders his
nephews you you get this Perpetual the
crown is is seductive of course of
course it's seductive you look at that
thing you look you look at how it holds
you you look at
those those extraordinary images of the
queen wearing the crown either the
coronation or particularly at the state
opening of parliament the the Imperial
State Crown that Master
there's the lights come up and I'm
watching that you can see why people
quite die kill murder
for the thing and I mean Harry
has that he also of course has the uh
extraordinary sense of white Knighthood
with his mother and and assumed with
Megan but all he's doing really is using
modern devices you know harpercollins is
the equivalent of um going into alliance
with the lancastrians against the
Yorkies you're deploying modern means to
get even
um
David isn't this
just what happens when you live a life
without purpose no and many people on
the contrary the struggles were much
more vicious when the Molly had a
profound purpose it's just called it's
called human it's called Humanity
Brothers quarrel human nature it's
called human nature Brothers quarrel in
many ways it's highly creative thing the
company male competition
um no I I don't think it's a I mean in
Harry's case it is but equally
you can see I mean one of the paradoxes
I mean let's now just quickly turn the
thing around the the whole notion of
print of King Charles and saying oh we
want to slim down monarchy now in one
sense that is exactly what might have
dealt with Harry you want to say right
you're the young the son you uh enjoy
rights and Royal privileges until
Denmark shows exactly the case that's
happened Queen Margaret has decided that
her younger son and his children shall
as it were be dis Royal because there is
now a secure succession with her Elder
son right and you could imagine that
erected into a rule that until the
succession is secure you know you will
retain everything and whatever but once
two three children sorry we give you
dignity we give you a pension we give
you uh every encouragement to go off and
do things but no longer Royal the
trouble is isn't it
that we've got a very different view of
monarchy have you noticed these
extraordinary ancient people even older
than me like the Duke of Kenton princess
Alexandra these people in their 80s I
mean the Duke of Kent looks until he's
going to drop dead any moment so he's
being wheeled out the whole of the time
because of course
all sorts of things have Royal patronage
the one of them you were talking about
not having a purpose one of the things
that the monarchy has become in the 20th
century is the essential patron of
voluntary activity organization after
organization rejoices in Royal Patriot
and the Royals do something now that
needs a lot of people you look at the
number of engagements of a Princess Anne
or of the queen or of King Charles now
you need space you need hyperspares you
need pre-generation spares but of course
you need those who are prepared for that
subordinate role
and again one just Marvels the problems
of Harry's education apparently it took
Megan to instruct him that monarchy was
hierarchical
can you imagine
can you imagine spelling
guys no the eye comes before the E and
there's an R there yeah and
but as you can imagine it would take a
very very long time but how have you
been
a royal Prince
how have you been in the Army how have
you been at Eaton Eaton is not exactly a
democratic institution and not
understood there's a thing called
hierarchy David do you not think this
speaks to very much the issue that we've
discussed with you in the past and we
speak often about on the show I think
that unwillingness to recognize the
existence whether you like it or not the
existence of hierarchy is part of this
new world view which seeks to make
everybody equal and that's the solution
as if that ever would happen as if that
would never work and I always say a No
sillier statement has ever been uttered
then we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are born free
and equal it is the silliest statement I
mean even women aren't born free and
equal
um Let me let me free myself immediately
from from the charge of misogyny a baby
is born a human baby is the most
dependent creature in existence
um it is it is absolutely incapable of
sustaining itself not for a week or two
not for a month or two but for years now
that seems to me to be a fundamental
fact about human beings and
the profound
inequality
of humankind and these are the things
that we should be ready in equal in
strength on the unequal and strength on
equal in mental strength on equal in
endurance unequal in in every quality
you can think of and which of course is
why we're so wonderful answer
standardized if we want to standardized
world we need to be turned into ants
which is exactly of course what what
um
regimes like communism and to an extent
Nazism endeavored to do when you're what
Chinese communism in particular it's
aspiration is to turn you into into in
into a human and in a functioning
antique the wonderful thing about being
human is precisely the diversity of the
separateness
um
um but I think the great curse I think
the great curse of the West is
in fact the beginning of the Declaration
of Independence I think the the uh the
thing that's held up here
we are a big American audience who by
the way love you
really really serious the uh I mean I
think Jefferson is the disaster of the
founding fathers this is the language of
the extreme Enlightenment this is the
language that leads to the catastrophe
in France um and what is very striking
is of course that those Notions of
equality figure nowhere in the
Constitution at all when you come to
draw a serious document that gives
America its extraordinary tensile
strength This brilliant brilliant
balancing between federalism and and in
other words the power of the states and
the creation of an acceptable Machinery
of of federal of central government and
astonishing you know the the way in
which the Senate is it becomes this kind
of tensile bomb this idea of of the
equal representation of States whatever
their size whatever their population it
it is an ex it is an extraordinary
document but it is merely a it is merely
a very lightly amended version of the
18th century English Constitution this
is this is exactly what John Adams says
that interestingly enough it's Tom Payne
who also says to Washington I think it's
this isn't is it second third letter I
lose track of these things I'm not an
American historian that says to
Washington you know that that we began
with the ASP allegedly never did begin
begin with the with the aspiration to
have a real Revolution and what we
finish up instead is merely a very
lightly amended version of the English
Constitution John Adams again that point
about Royal Republic I think in the
1760s said that it's unquested George
III it's unquestionable that England is
a republic it just happens to have a
crown head it's ruled by law the king is
under law
um uh uh uh uh and so on so but I think
the disaster is that opening phrase
which is very very effectively buried
that notion of equality it's very
effectively buried until Lincoln and
Gettysburg speech you know that we are a
nation founded on new principles the
principle of equality tell me where is
equality in 19th century America
tell me where is equality in you know in
the America of the Gilded Age the
quality of America is precise is wild
inequality
it's astonishing chaotic creativity held
together by
this miracle of words
and is this a story
and then of course the catastrophe is
that it's propagated by Eleanor
Roosevelt principally through the the
Machinery of the 40 of 1945 the United
Nations and particularly the universal
Declaration on human rights and I mean
have you
um have you I never know how you
pronounce his name
um what is the chat with with the
African sounding name the wonderful Dane
who's written about
freedom of speech
you really are I'm sorry my memory is so
bad you won't have him on the show but
what he points out what he shows is that
the the whole campaign for the
limitation of freedom of speech to
protect the right of minorities has been
driven using the universal Declaration
of Human Rights by the Soviets in other
words all all the Notions about
discrimination and whatever as we know
have been used to undo freedom of speech
um uh
actually derive from the negotiations in
this in the 50s and 60s
um to translate the universal
declaration into from merely a
declaration into a binding statement
with the Soviet Union satellites coming
up with this whole idea that we've got
to protect minorities the protection of
minorities is the thing that has always
been used to destroy freed and to
destroy the freedoms and to destroy
bills of Rights remember the original
purpose of the universal Declaration of
Human Rights is to protect the
individual against the state the moment
you say that the essential purpose of
Human Rights is to protect minorities
against majorities you then have to turn
the state into the Machinery that
protects the minority against the
majority you invert nachangama isn't it
you invert the process and it is this
worship of this silly word equality
forcing people into something that
they're not
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
this is what I want to get at with you
because this is a struggle as old as
time right who has how much power based
on what and who gets what and how do we
divide the assets that generate that are
generated in society and Humanity has
struggled for Millennia to answer that
question and communism and Nazism and
all these other things were attempts to
re-engineer humanity
what what what what have we learned
through our human history about those
attempts I mean I know the answer is
nothing yes
the fact that we keep on having to
repeat them would suggests to me merely
as a matter of empirical observation
um
in many ways we've learned enormous
amounts the uh we accidentally
I would argue we remember the notion of
representative government that we have
now which is pretty works pretty well we
stumbled on accidentally in Britain
England it really doesn't if you don't
find anything quite like it elsewhere
and
it it was there was this again so I am
I'm answering the question very art
adversely but
there are no great conservative thinkers
I would argue
conservatism doesn't lend itself to
thought in fact I don't think thinking
is a very conservative activity
um that's good that's the thing
I really don't think I don't you like
loving grenades in every direction it's
very important one of them should
particularly love the grenades at
oneself on one's own quiet and see if
they're standing I don't think thinking
there's a conservative activity what is
is a slow growth of a tradition of a way
of doing things and the the idea of
representative government in England the
idea of government grounded in law and
the limitations of law there's no one
individual there's there's no there's no
there's no there's not even well the
sort of Magna Carta but Magna cartas is
is a kind of tiny germ what then happens
is a whole series of things come
together a particular attitude to law
particular Kings come along one of of
the ways in which you've developed the
idea most strongly paradoxically is
because the English are addicted to
fighting they love the Kings love war
and they discover oddly enough that you
can actually raise taxation if you ask
nicely
um you know that you actually get
consent for it so it's actually the very
strong Kings who build up this machinery
and so on but it's what you do you
create you create a political tradition
and what we've got so badly wrong in the
west is to think that this political
tradition which gives us the right to do
what we are doing now
that gives us modern even the right is
the wrong word give we just think we're
entitled to do it we occasionally talk
about that as a right when we want to
invest it with solemnity in the same way
we tend to We tend to call things that
we think we ought to have Universal
human rights has there ever been a
sillier phrase you know the the uh again
Jeremy Bentham describes Universal
rights as nonsense on stilts right you
can only have a right with an enforcing
body with an enforcing body of law but
the the the the the the the the thing
that that we need to understand
is that
a particular way of doing things arose
in other words
it's rooted in a particular society
but be if you actually look at belief in
what we can Loosely call Representative
law bound government
it's profoundly shallow outside the
anglosphere
it really is
um in other words these things are not
Universal these things are not logically
deducible
these things do not arise from a fixed
human nature they arise from specific
localized historical experience
now this of course Cuts absolutely
against
what is virtually universally assumed
um I'm saying it quite deliberately as I
said I think the the great disaster of
the 20th century is the 1945 settlement
I think we can see in retrospect that
the 1945 settlement is as catastrophic
as that at the end of the first world
war tell us more well this is what I've
been trying to explain to you but it
seems to me that it it the the with with
the creation of a notion of universal
human rights and you and the universe
therefore a universal man that is
remember if you've got Universal human
rights that assumes there's a thing
called the universal map that is again
so far from Human Experience but was it
such a bad idea after seeing the horrors
of world war one and then the horrors of
the Holocaust to go maybe all humans
should have a right to life lack of
torture you know not have to have
medical procedures enforced on them was
that such a terrible idea of course not
and in one sense we you can see of
course you can see its immediate
profound attractiveness the trouble is
you root it in the wrong argument
um that in other words beyond the the
idea of human of human universality I
mean again let's let's just go back
um to how this idea arose one common
notion about how this idea how the idea
of human universality arose and Tom
Holland advances this very strongly in
Dominion is that it arises essentially
through Pauline Christianity and whether
you're familiar with with it's it's
particularly the epistle for the
Galatians and there what Paul says is
it's really worth repeating that there
is neither listen carefully there is
neither Jew nor Greek
bombed that slave nor free man nor woman
in Christ in other words that Christ
abolishes
human distinction but that doesn't mean
that human distinction is abolished no
nobody assumed that Christianity until
the woke came along was about abolishing
the difference between man and woman and
what it's saying is that there is in a
particular form of religion and
spirituality a Transcendence
of human difference
now I think that the only way in which
we can all get on is and again so I am
taking this right back to the beginning
of our conversation is recognizing human
diversity and difference and the last
way you can do that is if you start
producing universalized doctrines you I
can understand right I can understand
and now I'm thinking aloud I can
understand as it were the negative Thou
shalt not do yes that seems but that's
not a universal human value I can
understand the negative in the same way
I don't believe at all in do as you
would be done by I do believe don't do
what you wouldn't have done to you
in other words the Golden Rule seems to
me to be it works much better
in the negative than in the positive
because of course do as you would be
done by means I can enforce my values on
you are you bothered to think about it
so we're back to the Ten Commandments
again we're back to your point about
how do we cope with the extraordinary
diversity of human beings and it seems
to me that
yes in one sense we've learned nothing
in the abstract
in other ways I think we've learned
profoundly the development of traditions
of language of culture of thought of
manners the behavioral patterns of human
beings have changed have improved in
many ways I think and this again is a
reflection of age I think my sense is
that we've sort of gone a little bit off
the top in our own civilization maybe
rather a lot off the top that the
the cultivation of a civilization is uh
and it's I make it sound like a plant
and I think it is
uh in other words you can over crop you
can over prune you can over fertilize
it goes right back to the beginning of
our civilization which is the invention
of the English language
um which is Chaucer and Chaucer has this
astonishing phrase chauces of again and
an extraordinary man he's a product of
this strange Island On The Fringe of
Europe
um which didn't really have a language
you're at the stage you've killed the
native language of the Anglo-Saxon it's
got completely mixed up with the the
language of an of an alien ruling class
French and Chaucer
in some ways not quite single-handed of
course not but shapes it into a language
we forget to know English is the most
extraordinary recent of languages
English really is only well it's after
the beginning of Parliament
um that oath that I was talking about of
of Edward II in 1308 that sworn in Latin
and French
but Chaucer towards the end of that
Century begins to formulate English but
he formulates it against the background
of Latin and against the background of
Italian and his travels in Italy and one
of the things of course that's shaping
this world is the world of Rome that
dead great civilization which is to the
living civilization through its books
and its literature and its buildings
which Chaucer encounters particularly in
Italy and in one of his poems he writes
about his experience of reading one of
the most important surviving works of
Cicero the dreamer Scipio in which
Cicero reflects on the greatness of Rome
and Roman history and it's very
wonderful he goes to sleep he's both
stiff and he dreams not of a parliament
not of a senate of human beings but the
birds all making love to each other it's
a wonderful poem and then there's a
couplet in which he's reflecting on this
newly discovered world of of Roman
literature and whatever and the phrase
goes as follows
just in the same way and the point that
I made about a civilization as a kind of
culture as a kind of the kind of
Agriculture Justice says in the same way
that from the old Earth each year their
Springs new corn so from old books new
learning comes and that's it's that
extra and again it's what what Burke is
talking about when he talks about
society as a as a cross-generational
contract when he talks about it as if it
is a contract it's a contract between
those those of those who are living
those who were dead and those who were
yet to be born and it's this
fertilization across time and that's
that's why the American Revolution is a
success of the French Revolution as a
catastrophe the French Revolution tries
to restart time it tries to do what the
Chinese what the Russian does the
American Revolution effectively is just
a group of Englishmen deciding actually
they can run their Affairs better
David we've got to wrap up shortly but
you raised I think within that a
question that a lot of people actually
deeply I think deep down want to hear an
answer to which is you talk about our
civilization you talk about it as a
plant is it dying
well I think we're doing our best to
kill it I mean remember fundamentally
a civilization depends on one generation
handing on to the next
and many of my generation decided they
didn't want to do that and quite a lot
of yours decide they didn't want to
receive it and modernism
to a very significant extent began as
destruction we really do need to
understand this I mean the you look at
what we call Modern Art which begins
with Marcel Duchamp duchar did not think
he was inventing art dushan you know
he's the person with the urinal
uh in which which is then labeled
LaFontaine and all the way and and and
and with a fictitious signal signature
uh in in New York Marcel Duchamp does
not think he's inventing a new art
duchar is trying to destroy art he says
Rembrandts should be used as ironing
boards he says absolutely specifically I
am an an artist in the same way as an
anarchist I am absolutely opposed to Art
all that stuff the the the the the the
the the art of surrealism and whatever
and and dadaism is only reinvented as
art in the Warhol Circle in New York in
the 1960s and above all by a group of
money grubbing money grubbing Germans in
Italy who persuade duchong to
re-reissue his various works and it's
only in the 1960s that you decide this
stuff is art
um again the modern movement in
architecture is a deliberate attempt at
destroying
previous patterns of artistic Endeavor
which again I was thinking this
today being driven in from Islington to
the to to to to to the wonders of King's
cross uh Anson Pancras to catch the
trains gonna get me here
um and
when my taxi took me down through
um the squares of Islington
um uh crossed over at Richmond Avenue
Hemingford Road and whatever and then it
turned towards Caledonian route and
these elegant Terraces and pretty Villas
suddenly turn into block after block
it is decaying little stream paint
peeling pissed upon cancer flats and you
look at a sense of a civilization having
committed visual suicide the sheer and
redeemed hideous ugliness and again it's
so much of the city the preening
preening swish my [__] bigger than your
skyscraper vanity of it there really is
this you look at that deliberate visual
chaos
you can't trust it
with the instinctive elegance and I'm
sounding like Prince Charles I apologize
elegance and human scale
um there is again when when people talk
about
everybody laughs when they say we've got
to build a beautiful but you look at the
[__]
ugliness
of so much modern house
the sheer ugliness of the spaces we
create the absolute indifference to the
human scale to Beauty to to even
Elementary convenience
and it is this extraordinary Paradox
that you know we've created levels of of
health of security of comfort
and at the same time
how can I put this bloody chat upon
a tradition of
civility but it's above all
in other words
we've forgotten that things really do
have to be transmitted that that the
culture is is a delicate thing and again
all the all you know the bloom stuff
about the closing of the American mind
about this is true
that that if if Generations are not
taught this you don't you don't absorb
Shakespeare by accident I mean and again
it's very but but
look at look at the role
in um the book that seems to me to be
the prophecy of what's happening to us
is Brave New World uh Brave New World
that society which which Huxley sees to
an extent experiences in twenties
California
um in which the only person who reads
Shakespeare is the Savage
um
that world of absolute valuelessness
there is a risk
there is a risk and the more we decide
that the Western tradition is a disaster
that whiteness is a disaster
then I'm afraid we are signing our own
death world you see there is a very we
we we were talking quite likely about
um cancel Katrina Andrew Doyle's written
brilliantly on this and about cancer
culture and all the rest of it
um being quasi-religious but there is an
example of a civilization which got
religion very badly and a religion that
was profoundly opposed to its Central
values it's called the Roman Empire and
Christianity and the classic account of
the fall of Rome that's to say uh Gibbon
sees the absorption of Christianity
which is a religion which in cognorantly
Rome embraced power it embraced dignity
it embraced honor
Christianity is religion which Embraces
submission
unitive forgiveness meekness meekness as
as Nietzsche says the religion of the
slave
foreign
and on that note David it's been an
absolute pleasure to have you on thank
you so much for coming on uh before we
do our questions for locals we always
ask the same question to end our
interviews which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that we really should be I think this
discussion has covered absolutely yes
seriously it went in wildly different
than directions from what I was
expecting and I'm sorry I I probably
wandered into far too many strange
corners but it does seem
important to say these things
um it is I mean I am aware and again it
is terrible age one becomes very aware
of fragility you become particularly
aware when like me you're childless I
never thought
I would say that it certainly never say
it publicly
but the only thing that someone like me
could have as a legacy and again all
football starts thinking of these things
is that process of transmission there
used to be the notion of in a sense
Master handing on to pupil
it's very difficult to preserve
and
wherever you look really
that's what's needed you you you
the trouble is that we we've tended to
see it as
um
strangling creativity we've come again
we were joking before weren't we
that that you need Rebellion you're
saying but you also need order in some
ways I suppose it is right to burn
Heretics
there is this awful paradox
um we've got a pie already just outside
already outside it was getting a little
warming yes David if I may pay you a
compliment before we let you go
um I think in terms of passing things on
this is quite the discussion in which
you've been able to do that and previous
conversations we have with you we have a
lot of young people who watch the show
some of them are even as young as in
being in their 40s
um and so something even younger than
you some even younger than very
difficult no but I I think
as we've seen with the growth of our
Channel you we joked earlier about when
you first came on the show was in a
dingy smelly Pub and look at us now
we're doing very well I think there's a
hunger
out there in the world I'm sure no I'm
sure sure there is but of course there
is a conspiracy not to feed that hunger
well we're conspiring to feed it to
deliberately starve it or to do what's
even worse to feed it rubbish food yes
yes but we run a small restaurant here
that focuses on high quality game man
you've done that today
David uh absolute pleasure I recommend
everybody check out your YouTube channel
where you put out a lot of great stuff
we're going to ask you a couple of
questions that are paying supporters
have submitted from locals uh but for
now thank you so much for joining us and
thank you for being with us we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or show all of
them go out at 7 pm UK time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
our civilizations always destined to
fall apart could a sufficient degree of
robustness ever be built into one
[Music]